now if you're a Christian and you've
been paying attention to Trump's pro-war
rhetoric wouldn't it be nice if we
struck first more countries should have
nuclear weapons it shouldn't be that big
of a deal if we use nuclear weapons on
somebody else if you're a true Christian
and you actually follow many of the
teachings of Jesus Christ which I don't
but I know many people in this country
do you would probably think there's
really nothing compatible between my
Christian values and those of Donald
Trump although Donald Trump did receive
a plurality of the evangelical vote in
the Republican primary earlier this
campaign season 78% of white evangelical
Christians said I plan to vote for
Donald Trump now the flagship magazine
of evangelical Christianity is blasting
Donald Trump and slamming Christians who
plan to vote for Trump here is a quote
that I want to put up for you and
discuss from Christianity today this is
from editorial director Andy Crouch now
as a reminder Christianity today was
founded by evangelist Billy Graham in
1956 okay that's for context as to what
what magazine this is coming from quote
enthusiasm for a candidate like Trump
gives our neighbors ample reason to
doubt that we believe Jesus is Lord they
see that some of us are so
self-interested and so self protective
that we will Ally ourselves with someone
who violates all that is sacred to us do
you understand what that saying that
Christians who are falling victims who
are becoming the prey of Donald Trump's
rhetoric are not being good Christians
now I'm not Christian quite quite
honestly I don't really care about
analyzing Donald Trump specifically from
a Christian lens but many people do and
Christianity today is spot on how can
you disagree with them that there is
nothing Christian there is nothing
representative about what Christian
values should be about the Donald Trump
campaign when I turn on CNN and I see
Kayleigh McKenna knee Trump supporter
wearing her gold or whatever kind of
cross necklace that that she wears on
every show and hear her defend Donald
Trump in terms of the comments he made
about grabbing women's [ __ ] when he
wants defending Donald Trump last night
as I was watching TV Don Lemon defending
Trump in light of all of these
allegations about sexual assault which
don't run contrary to anything Trump has
ever said but rather just are
representative of what Trump is on
record as having said for a long time I
say to myself what's Christian about
Donald Trump and how can a
self-professed Christian like Caylee
McKenna knee or whoever it is that's
saying I'm voting for Trump because he's
the Christian candidate it's it's just
really disturbing Pat because there's
nothing Christian about this guy is
there and to the best of my knowledge
he's still leading in the polls amongst
evangelicals yeah it's cuz they always
have that excuse in their back pocket
that well we promote forgiveness and
redemption so we're gonna forgive we're
gonna give them a pass on this one yeah
except Trump's not born again right I
mean with george w bush you could at
least i think this is cuckoo for cocoa
puffs right i mean i'm not defending
this in any way this is completely crazy
but you could at least have a credible
case that in spite of all the bad stuff
that george w bush did he was born again
he's a born-again christian and by the
internal logic of being born again we
now have this rebirth and were starting
from scratch which door with george w
bush okay i don't buy into this but some
people do trump's not a born-again
christian i mean he's basically found
his christianity fifteen months ago or
18 months ago whenever he started
running for president saying that the
bible is his second favorite book or
first favorite book alongside the art of
the deal the book that someone else
ghost wrote for him the only thing in
common really between trumps book art of
the deal and the bible is that neither
were written by Trump and our books that
maybe he's glanced at at some point in
his life but that's about it and and
there's not even a bogus seemingly
credible case because as you're pointing
out Trump is not born again right why
are we just saying oh we'll skip
everything Trump did because it was a
while ago it's like they're trying to
find a reason to still support him yeah
despite that fact yeah it's digging
pretty deep and I
it is all imploding I mean it's it's all
coming off the walls
it is crumbling right now for Trump and
we only have a couple of weeks left and
then we're going to see how this thing
shapes up discuss this on our reddit
discussion forum by going to david
pakman.com slash read it that's our EDD
i.t back after this